ولا تعرف اكثر عن تنزه المشجع من الاحساء
ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي عبد الرحمن يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
صباح الخير سهام وصباح الخير نادين واهلا
وسهلا فيكم من هذه المحافظه الجميله نستمر
في جولتنا الجميله في معالم الاحساء التي
تستعد لاستقبال الاف المشجعين القادمين من
قطر او حتى الذاهبين الى قطر عبر المنفذ
الحدودي منفذ سلوى الرابط بين السعوديه
وقطر هذا المنتجع المتنزه الجميل جدا
المليء بالاشجار حتى اهالي الحسا يسمونه
المشتل وليس المنتزه من كثره الورود
والاشجار الجميله في العل زميلي علي ياخذ
لكم جوله في هذا المكان لتطلعوا اكثر على
تفاصيل طبعا هذا المنتجع كان فيه حسن قديم
جدا يسمى حصن العرب التليد وايضا بجانبه
سوق عربي شهير جدا يعود عمره الى قرون
الجاهليه همم القديمه الى سنه 20 ميلاديه
وما بعدها
من تم بناء هذا الحصن وتصميمه على غرار
الحصن القديم ليشابهه بالتصميم والشكل
طبعا تم تجديد هذا المنتزه بالكامل ليصبح
اكبر منتزه مساحه في الاحساء وهو اكبر
منتزه مفتوح في الاحساء متوقع ايضا ان
يحتضن هذا المنتزه قريه للمشجعين يكون
فيها شاشات لمتابعه المباريات وايضا اا
تقديم ال- ال- الوجبات وايضا فعاليات همم
السياحيه اذا ما تعرفنا عن تاريخ هذا مكان
نعم تفضل يعني
بس على قصه التاريخ بلشت تقول لنا متنزه
وقلت لنا كمان يسموه مشتل لكثره الاشجار
في بس انا عندي فضول اعرف ليش سموه مشجر
اكيد في لها قصه
صحيح هو سبب التسميه انه كان يطلع سابقا
اييي تقريبا الصبغ احمر
وهذا الصبغ يعني قريب من اللون الاشقر
فلذلك سمو العرب بالمشجر لانه كان السور
او الحصن المحاط بهذا المكان لونه برتقالي
يميل الى البني فلذلك سميع لكن الجميل
ايضا انه هذا الحصن يقال تاريخيا بان الذي
بناه هو قسم باللهوذ بن عمليق بن سام ابن
النبي نوح عليه السلام قبل تقريبا خمسه
الاف عام همم الموقع هذا كان يسمى سابقا
متسها الشيباني ثم همم سمي مؤخرا باسم
الحصن القديم اللي مشجر همم طبعا همم تم
استثماره سياحيه هذا الموقع تملكه وزاره
الزراعه والبيئه والمياه السعوديه لكن تم
تاجيره على المستثمرين هنا همم في همم
محافظه الاحساء ليتم تهيئته من جديد وفتحي
للناس طبعا الدخول الى هذا المنتزه يعني
سعر رمزي جدا تقريبا حوالي يعني اثنين
دولار همم امريكي حوالي 10 ريال سعودي
والاطفال الدخول مجانا هناك عديد من
فعاليات الموسيقيه هناك ايضا مساحات
مفتوحه همم
لفنانين والاعمال الفنيه هنا في الاحساء
فهذا المكان اصبح تقريبا
للفنانين في المنطقه وايضا المبدعين همم
لمبدعين الاحساء طبعا ايضا همم في الاعياد
في المناسبات يصبح هذا المكان ساحه كبيره
للاهالي لقضاء اوقات جميله والجميل ايضا
انه يفتح ابوابه حتى الساعه الثانيه صباحا
يعني تقريبا بعد منتصف الليل فهذا ايضا
ميزه تجعل الناس تاتي اليها اكثر فاكثر
خاصه مع الان الاجواء اللطيفه وهمم الهوى
قليله اللي اصبح الان اا يعني في نوفمبر
التوقيت ايضا جدا ممتاز بالنسبه لمشجعين
كاس عالم هيستمرون بشكل كبير هنا في هذا
المنتزه خلال الايام القليله المقبله
طيب عبد الرحمن عادل من متابعي كاس العالم
للمونديال بده يشاركنا محمد السعوديه
تابعوني
كاس العالم
عبد الرحمن